من البيت الابيض اعلان الرئيس جو بعد ان
لاعبه كره السله الامريكيه بريتني جراينر
[موسيقى]
من اعتقال اللاعب الفائزه بميداليتين
ذهبيتين اولمبيتين بتهمي
بمخدرات الى روسيا دراينر 31 عاما تعتبر
من افضل لاعب كره السله في العالم وصلت
الى روسيا في فبراير من اجل اللاعبين ضمن
احد النوادي في الاورال خلال فتره توقف
الدوري الامريكي الامر الذي دفع بالاتحاد
النساء لكره السله الامريكيه من الاعتراض
على اعتقالها واعتبارها اعتقالا
ظالمين قوي
وانت بخير
عمليات تبادل الاسرى شهره بين البلدين منذ
الحرب البارده ولم يفضح عن بنودها
في الوقت الذي تحتفل فيه عائله
من السجناء الامريكيين قابعين في السجون
الروسيه دون معرفه مصيرهم او موعد انتهاء
معاناتهم مع عدم اعلان الاداره الامريكيه
اي خطوات فعاليه لاستمرار اي مفاوضات مع
روسيا حول اوضاعهم سليمان العربيه